I mean her and I the other day we try to
make lovin from the dog it doesn't work
also first of all yeah I don't know how
it works anyway baby pack up what the
[ __ ] do you mean my friend what in God's
name do you mean my friend I'm just
saying it's like a Cabbage Patch doll
there you go that's all I wanna know I
get what you're right now a Barbie how
does it work okay let me just sitting
right now aiming there make a stick
there's a stick there's a hole right no
I can figure it out
mm-hmm okay those angles different ways
to go in let's say the hole yeah like
four feet higher then you just so I'm
one of you about the dog [ __ ] let me
here
well so we okay so yeah did anyone come
no one no she faked it just a dog I
didn't know was just kept touching me
over yeah
but also this guy the dog him how he set
the mood he set the mood by playing a
documentary about kids in Aleppo Syria
yeah
he saved some under the rubble white
helmets what it's great document and
then he whips his dick out why my main
tears why did I get you horny it doesn't
get me horny but I like to set the mood
in a [ __ ] uncomfortable way to lower
expectations yeah there you go
I get it Regina dry as a [ __ ] Sahara
yeah yeah yeah did something happen
yesterday what happened yesterday I was
here I'm going to sleep and I'm about to
fall exactly getting up early right
right and cloudless in the shower and
I'm literally like this is right here oh
that's how she Florida
it literally so my life is that carnival
crew she got out of the shower right and
wanted to fire no no no heat into the
room to see if I was sleeping all clear
pretended that I was sleeping and then
she's like she went back in the shower
I'm sorry I think that her farting is on
the scale of you watching Aleppo
documentary it was a great to sound
that's all what everyone really wants to
know is how was Bobby at eating [ __ ]
that's what we all want to know mm-hmm
you know what he hasn't eaten [ __ ] in a
long time really I'm outraged we haven't
even made out it's just straight like
coitus just full-on yeah because you
know the problem now is you guys are
like brother and sister your party here
I love my girlfriend so much I know I'm
trying to savage on you don't see me
trying to sabotage this [ __ ] yeah